[Music]
good evening everybody and welcome to
our debate clank and the consciousness
puzzle my name is catherine heymans i'm
a professor of astrophysics at the
university of edinburgh and i'm also the
astronomer royal for scotland now most
of us scientists included see physics as
an attempt to provide an objective
description of the world independent of
human subjectivity and consciousness yet
max planck one of the major scientific
figures of the 20th century and the
founder of quantum mechanics stated as a
result of his investigations and
experiments
i regard consciousness as fundamental
i regard mata as derivative from
consciousness
should we listen to planck can we
plausibly see mata as a derivative of
consciousness
might doing so help solve the deep
puzzles facing contemporary physics and
overcome the hard problem of
consciousness itself
or does this outlook as einstein argued
undermine the very success and
objectivity of science and take us back
to a world of superstition and to help
me answer those questions this evening i
am joined by a fantastic
panel of scientists and um philosophers
patricia churchland uh she's professor
of philosophy at the university of
california
and she's a pioneer of neurophyllis
philosophy and that's philosophy
transformed by the advances of
neuroscience she brings cutting-edge
empirical research to bear on the
questions of mind that have been
plaguing us for millennia and her latest
book consciousness explores how moral
systems arise um from our physical
selves in combination with environmental
demands amanda geffer now she is a
brilliant writer specializing in
fundamental physics cosmology cognitive
science and philosophy and her
award-winning book trespassing on
einstein's law is a memoir of family
bonding and cutting-edge physics and she
also hosts a book lab which is a podcast
about popular science books and with the
science journalist dan falc
we're honored this evening to have brian
green with us professor of physics and
mathematics uh world-renowned for his
groundbreaking discoveries in the field
of superstring theory including the
co-discovery of mirror symmetry and the
discovery of spatial topology change now
professor green is known to the public
through his new york times best-selling
books and numerous media appearances
including the late show with stephen
colbert
and finally let me introduce you to
laura massini horton as she is a world
leading cosmologist and professor at the
university of north carolina now her
work led for the first time to a theory
of the origin of our universe from the
multiverse and crucially she showed for
the first time that we can test
structures before our universe existed
and beyond the horizon now we're going
to um start our debate um i'm going to
give each of our panelists two minutes
and to answer the question for me this
evening which is was plank right is
consciousness fundamental and i'm going
to start off with pat churchill and pat
was planned right
thanks very much well they're really two
approaches to trying to understand the
nature of the variety of conscious
phenomena and one is to devise a great
grand exotic
very surprising theory
and that approach is usually heavy on
metaphor and very shy on data
now the other approach is to find
very specific
conscious phenomena
that we can address in a neurobiological
context because we think at least that
things that have nervous systems also
tend to have if they are mammals at any
rate they tend to have conscious
experiences
and one of the most successful
i think has to do with understanding
precisely what happens in brains
when people lose consciousness when
they're given a general anesthetic such
as propofol
exactly what happens to very specific
cells
and what happens when the propofol is
reduced and the person slowly regains
consciousness
and we can see that that what happens in
a monkey
when we do the recording right on the
cells themselves is very consistent with
what we discover happens
in humans when they undergo these
changes now this looks like a brain
phenomenon
um
and i'm quite happy to have it shown to
me uh that you know something else is
going on
but this particular instance along with
certain others having to do with uh deep
sleep for example suggests that
it's a neuronal business at the moment
um amanda guetta was plank right is
consciousness fundamental
um
so well first of all thanks for having
me here it's amazing to be among these
brilliant people um
so i i would say no i don't think
consciousness is fundamental um but i
don't think matter is fundamental either
and so
throughout history we've sort of bounced
between these two extremes like either
everything is mined or everything is
matter
and i think quantum mechanics actually
can help us sort of break the stalemate
um
so the deepest thing that i have learned
about quantum mechanics and this really
comes from niels bohr is that quantum in
quantum mechanics subject and object are
sort of profoundly coupled
they're sort of stuck together they
define each other in this kind of
contextual way through interaction
and in a sense this really changes the
whole game because if subject and object
are coupled
then we have to rethink what we mean by
the world and also what we mean by the
observer and so on the side of the world
we've sort of been forced to give up
this classical notion that there's just
like a ready-made world that's sitting
there with definite features that just
are some particular way that can be
described from a kind of third person
god's eye view
um
and i think that lesson people sort of
work in foundations of quantum mechanics
have taken to heart but i think what we
still haven't quite come to grips with
yet is what that means for our notion of
the observer too so this kind of old
school cartesian view of the observer as
this
passive spectator who lives in our heads
and represents the world without
interfering in it without interacting
with it just isn't quite gonna work in
this picture so i think the very idea of
consciousness even if we just think of
it as a function of the brain if we
really think of it as being separated
from our dynamic bodily engagement with
the world then it sort of is just this
carryover from this newtonian way of
thinking where the world out there
already is some particular way and now
the mind in here has to model it or
contemplate it from afar and those
things are functionally decoupled i
think if subject object coupling is
really at the heart of reality then that
idea has to be rethought
so i don't think consciousness is
fundamental because i don't think the
idea of consciousness totally makes
sense in the quantum mechanical universe
in the same way that the classical view
of matter doesn't quite make sense in a
quantum mechanical universe
thank you amanda um brian green
was plank right is consciousness
fundamental
i don't know
maybe i'll take it a little bit a little
bit beyond that um no but i think that
really is the answer i don't think we
know and i i mean that in a not a
flippant sense i mean in a kind of
profound sense i mean pat can speak to
this with far greater authority than i
can but i don't think there's anybody on
the planet who knows what consciousness
is at some deep fundamental level and i
can speak with authority
on my own part to say that when it comes
to quantum mechanics there are deep
unsolved qualities of quantum mechanics
which is shocking
we've been using this theory since the
1920s to make the most precise
predictions in all of science to
manipulate matter with fantastic
precision it all works but there are
deep questions about what it actually
tells us about
the nature of the world and so yes i
think the the the full answer that we
can truthfully give you today is
i don't know we don't know but if you
have it for a sort of gut feel
my intuition my intuition is that plank
was not
right
my intuition as well is that amanda's
description which
reflects deep thinking of niels bohr i
don't think that's right either
i don't think that the issue of subject
and object which was vital to the early
thinking about quantum mechanics has a
full place in our most precise
understanding of reality all i think is
their stuff
and sometimes that stuff
accumulates into what we call an
observer sometimes that stuff
accumulates into what we call an object
and stuff interacts with stuff via the
laws of quantum mechanics and there's a
lot about that interaction that we
understand
there's a lot however that still remains
to be fully understood
thank you brian and last but not least
uh laura mercini horton
what do you think was plank right
i don't know
it's um
if
if i had to take a position on
his statement
i would say that
matter being the derivative of
consciousness is does not sound correct
but we don't know what consciousness is
on on the other hand uh we do know
uh
uh enough about the brain
to at least say with confidence that not
everything that happens there and
therefore gives rise to cognitive or
mental processes to the mind is quantum
mechanical so in in that
respect i wouldn't agree with uh
amanda i i
probably agree with uh brian
for example neuron firings are
non-linear
and then we know that quantum mechanics
is linear perhaps neural transmission in
the mind
as a linear process might be
explainable with quantum mechanics but
definitely not
not the neuron firings we should
eventually give rise to the corrugations
that amanda was talking about so trying
to find common grounds with uh
boars
collapse of the wave function and
observer and subject
or or um or with junk's version of the
quantum mechanics connection to the mind
i think is an oversimplified way to go
we definitely
don't know
why
we even need to experience
the the subjective side which is the
heart problem of consciousness we might
be able to
explain it at a
basic level the easy problem of
consciences in in other words to map
certain brain processes to certain
mental states
but but we we cannot explain why do we
need to have the subjective experience
of those mental states and and why do we
have that but other species uh some
other species don't
so there is a lot in in that thought
that if i were forced to to take a
decision i would say
that consciousness is a much harder
problem than any problem i've
encountered in physics including dark
energy
and the origin of the universe
okay well there you go we are going to
be discussing something that is more
complex than the origin of the universe
thank you laura
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas